- When he broke the sign in Dodger
Stadium during batting practice,
I went in. This is a playoff
game, mind you.
- Mm-hmm.
- I went in, I said, "Hey, I need
some Dodger letterhead."
I had it typed up, "Hey, on behalf
of the Los Angeles Dodgers,
we are fining you $10,000 for breaking the sign."
Signed so and so.
And I put it on his chair, and
he looked at it, he goes,
"What should I do?" Now, this is
30 minutes before the first pitch.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "You gotta pay it."
- [Laughing]
♪♪♪
- [Master Tesfatsion] So who
we got in the pool hall today?
- [Curtis Granderson] What's going on man?
-  Curtis Granderson, what's
good with you baby?
-  Man, I'm all good. Appreciate
you having me here.
- Hey man, it’s good chopping up with
you. Let’s see how you break though.
-  All right, let's see.
- Let’s see how nice you are.
- Let's see.
All right.
- So where did you
start off? High A or like-
- I started off in Short-Season
A in Oneonta, New York.
Small town. I remember my scout
that drafted me, Jerome Cochran said,
"Man you gonna love it. It's beautiful up
there. It's a ton of trees and everything."
It was a lot of trees but it wasn’t
nothing else up there. Oh, man.
- I mean we see it a lot in
terms of the Minor Leagues.
You've got people who are coming
from the Dominican. Venezuela.
And they're also coming through
the same ranks as you talk about.
How did you assimilate with all these different
people from all these different cultures
that you probably never been
open or experienced to?
- You know, growing up in Chicago, even
though I had Sammy Sosa playing for the Cubs
or Ozzie Guillén playing for the White Sox,
this is a little- hey, don't get mad at me
Sammy. Don't get mad at me Ozzie.
I thought they were Black, right?
They look like me, they
were playing baseball.
I thought Sammy Sosa was Black. I had never
seen no one with the last name Sosa before.
I just thought it was a different last name.
When I joined my team the first time,
I remember getting on the bus
and I said man, this is the most
Black players I ever played with.
Now remember again, I'm coming from thinking
Ozzie is Black, thinking Sammy is Black.
So I see everyone that looked
like me and I go, “What's going on?
How you doing? You know. Hello, hello.
How's everybody doing? What's going on?”
And no one's saying anything.
So now I get in the back of the bus, the
bus starts going, the music starts playing.
Now I start hearing the Latin music. I go,
“Oh. Latin, Dominican, Venezuelan.”
And I realize that although we look very
similar, we're still slightly different.
And then that started that process of understanding
OK, there's a whole different world out
there besides Chicago where I grew up
and I wanted to learn it. I wanted to take it in.
And I was excited to get a chance to
be on that team to start my career.
[Balls hitting, ball dropping into pocket]
- There we go.
- So I've been in clubhouses before.
I've covered baseball teams.
And it's always been interesting
to me being in a clubhouse,
knowing that there's probably going
to be two leaders in a clubhouse.
One of them, who's a leader
for the Latin players.
- Mm-hmm.
- And the other one who's like
the English speaking leader.
- Yup.
- And most of the time, let's be
honest, it's probably a white dude.
- Mm-hmm.
- As a Black man, how did
you fit in this dynamic
when you're trying to
figure out where you fit in?
- As a Black man in a baseball
team, we were the minority.
So I think that helped us kind of be
right in the middle of both sides.
And I think both of them knew, "OK, cool."
We're here for you if you need us.
We’re here for you if you need us.
You need us to translate and, and bring it over
here to make you feel a little more comfortable?
We can do that.
"How come they playing the music
so loud?" "We like it loud too.
OK, you want me to tell them turn it down?
I'll tell them to turn it down a little bit."
"OK, why they always listening
to country and cowboy boots?"
- Man, they love some country music, bro.
- "Man, that's what they
like too," you know?
And then here we go, I got
Yoenis Céspedes. Man.
He probably the country-est Latin Cuban dude.
- [Laughing]
He rode to the stadium on a horse.
On a horse! Not a car.
Not a bike. On a horse.
This dude rode a horse. And so,
man buckles so big. And man.
- But still got them neon
yellow sleeves on, like…
- So imagine that. Neon yellow sleeve,
hit home runs, and ride a
horse at the same- man.
So, if this dude wasn't fitting in with everybody, who else could?
- [Laughing]
- My shot here? Let’s see.
Where we at? Where we at?
- I think you got it.
- Oh man, it’s gonna be a tight one.
- There you go. There
you go. That’s going in.
- Get legs.
- Oh!
- There we go. There we go.
- You talked a lot about clubhouse
camaraderie and clubhouse chemistry.
How was that one, the 2015 Mets team?
- So that team, I think had no standout player.
Céspedes was probably the biggest one,
but he still was getting his wings underneath him, right?
David Wright was coming off of injury.
Michael Cuddyer had just come to us,
but he was for the Twins and a lot of
people didn't watch the Twins that much.
We start rolling.
Daniel Murphy has probably the
best playoffs I've ever seen.
That's not the guy you were
trying to not let beat you, right?
- Was anyone accounting for that, or no?
- I don't think anyone saw that coming.
I mean, we go into Wrigley Field and he's
hitting the balls left and right, all over the place,
and then in Dodger Stadium, that first round,
Duda's breaking signs in batting practice.
- [Laughing]
And the thing about Duda is he's just
so quiet and so calm and reserved.
But again, we're locker mates.
And we both bat left-handed.
So we had so many things in common,
so I always messed with him.
And here comes the "We Follow
Lucas Duda" Instagram page.
- Tell me about that, yeah.
How'd that come together?
- He was starting to get hot that
year. I think he hit 30 home runs.
And I was like, "Duda, you
got to be on social media."
"Nah, nah, nah. I don't like social
media. I don't want any of that."
And we took a picture of
him and created the page.
That was it. We didn't
expect anything else.
And that page got to 100,000 followers like this.
So now it became our whole
team was all trying to stalk him
and just catch him in different moments.
When he broke the sign in Dodger
Stadium during batting practice,
I went in. This is a playoff
game, mind you.
This is just where my mind is.
I want to keep everybody loose.
I went in, I said, "Hey, I need some
Dodger letterhead on a piece of paper."
So I got Dodger letterhead, I had it typed up,
"Hey, on behalf of the Los Angeles Dodgers,
we are fining you $10,000 for breaking the sign."
Signed so and so. And I put it on his chair,
and he looked at it, he
goes, "What should I do?"
Now, this is 30 minutes
before the first pitch.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "What do you think I should do with this?"
“You've got to pay it.”
- [Laughing]
- You've got to pay- Nah.
And he went out there and had a
great series. Duda did a great series.
We beat the Dodgers in Dodger Stadium.
So little things like that just
to keep everybody loose.
The We Follow Lucas Duda Instagram account,
all that stuff, I think, just helped play into it all.
- And we kept going. And then
once we got to the World Series,
we just came up a little bit short there.
That first game, in Kansas City, we were up.
Alex Gordon hits a home run to
put it into extras. I was like, "Oh."
Not losing that game, but
going to New York down 0-2,
versus going to New York 1 to 1- because I
think we were going to lose the second game.
They, they, they played really well.
That puts us in a different situation.
Because everyone says Game 3 is the
turning point and we won Game 3.
Then it was just playing catch-up at that
point in time and we ran out of juice.
- Yeah.
- You know? The Citi Field, the
blue and orange, the Seven Line,
the homers out of the ballpark.
We just came up a little short.
But I wouldn't trade anything from that season.
It was great because no one expected
it, and that's what you want to be.
Expect the unexpected.
- For sure. I think it’s your shot, right?
- We got insurance on the place, right?
We good?
- Oh, I- I think so.
- OK, all right, good. Then
we might- I may try it.
You know what then, let me try it then.
- Go ahead, yeah. Let’s see what you can do.
- Let's see.
- Oh!
- There we go. Yeah, you know?
- Aye.
- Something slight.
♪♪♪
- Now Curtis, your real childhood
passion was basketball?
- Man, I wanted to hoop for as long as I
could but you can see the height just didn’t-
- [Laughing]
- It slowed down for a little bit.
- Well let’s see how nice you are
on the Pop-A-Shot. Is that cool?
- Let’s do it.
- You got 60 seconds. Go and hit the button.
[Digital beeps from game sounding]
- Come on, bring them balls out.
- I’m gonna ask you questions the whole
time. It’s gonna be fast. All right, you ready?
- All right. Let’s go.
- Who are you listening to before a game?
- Outkast.
- Mets or Yankees?
- Mets.
- Hardest pitcher to hit off of?
- Brad Hand.
- Funniest opponent you’ve played?
- Uh, Sean Casey.
- A-Rod or Jeter?
- Jeter.
- Favorite wrestler?
- Junkyard Dog.
- Best slugger in baseball?
- Miguel Cabrera.
- Queens or the Bronx?
- Uh, Bronx. I get my hair cut there.
- Boogie Down. You got to.
They’re gonna cut your hair up.
[Laughing]
- Right?
- Dirtiest opponent you’ve faced?
- The Nationals.
- Best MLB mascot?
- Mr. Met.
- One player, former or current, you
wish you could’ve played with?
- Jackie Robinson.
- Funniest teammate you’ve had?
- Bartolo Colón.
- Chewing gum or sunflower seeds?
- Gum.
- Worst fans in baseball?
- Uh...
I don’t know.
- 3, 2, 1.
Come on you gotta say something.
You gotta say something!
- Uh.
- I know you got somebody you can’t stand.
- Uh, no no. Uh. Philly, man.
I think the fans- they booed Santa Claus
from what I heard back in the day.
- Philly fans are terrible.
That’s a great one to pick.
- [Laughing]
But they didn’t throw no
batteries at me though.
- [Laughing]
Curtis, appreciate you for
coming to the pool hall, man.
- Thank you for having me.
- Appreciate y’all for watching.